Ukraine is finally on the March
defensive operations switched to
offensive ones
just this morning as the battle
continued nearby Ukrainian troops
claimed they'd liberated storage of air
in the dunetsk region
at first we were made with heavy Russian
Artillery said this Soldier but then we
took it back house by house celebrations
are muted though there is no time to
pause they must continue pressing
forward over the weekend in the village
of La houdatney Fighters were seen
trading gingerly through the ruins of
another shattered building before
hoisting the Ukrainian flag through the
smashed window of what used to be a
local community center
we're kicking the enemy out Sid this
Soldier it is the warmest feeling there
is